[Music]
hunting season you know no one has his
number what are you up to these days
evening the odds this is the team I
could work around actually I would
rather if you it's refreshing you
actually know what you're doing down
there yeah that's what she said
hey Wow like always the dough you're my
eyes in the sky
sound a cage a connection we move
everyone needs backup
created between the lines kick some ass
get the girl and try to look dope try
you do it
three you wanted me back you could have
just asked me
the device that controls every military
satellite in the world has fallen into
the hands of four very dangerous guys we
need someone who can move like them
fight like them it's time to be patriot
there are no more Patriots just rebel
and tyrants so which are you I'm xxx
I'll introduce you to your ground team
all right it comes red poster child
I'm not gonna have clowns watch my back
who would you trust
[Music]
now that the team I can work with there
you go
refreshing if you know what you're doing
down there yeah that's what she says Wow
these Casey Jones are the real kind of
trouble you have no idea what you're up
against whatever it is they're looking
for we're gonna come up short does this
mean you're not making me breakfast in
the water we're willing to die to keep
the world safe how about you I live for
this I guess we're on the same team now
you ready to have some fun I go along
we simple fastly kick some ass get the
girl and try to look dope why are you
doing
[Music]
dan it feels good to be back you know
they say the world is safer than has
ever been in the history of civilization
do you feel safer today than you did
yesterday I know I don't
the world has changed war we're fighting
today
needs a different kind of soldier
we need people with the skills and the
attitude
to take on threats we don't even know
exist
we need someone who can walk into a
tornado and come out the other side like
it was a damn gentle breeze one in the
back
you could've just asked me we simplify
for you kick some ass
and try to look dope why are you doing
I could definitely make that work
guns girls global domination
and the cages back
you